foreign
Luis starts us off in Atlanta Luis
welcome to the show
hey thank you for having me how's it
going
oh good thank you how can we help today
so um rent is really expensive
true and uh I'm really considering van
life and I wanted to know your opinion
and any tips or
foreign
are you gonna park it down by a river
whatever I can you're gonna have to
Google that reference later dude don't
move into a van down by the river why
are you considering van life why are the
options either uh continue you can't
continue to live where you live rent is
too expensive but the other option is
moving to a van how did you get to that
option
um so I just saw it
on Instagram
and I don't know I thought it was a good
idea
did someone on Instagram say it was a
good idea they said hey life hack can't
afford rent live in a van or they just
I've seen them Hey listen Lewis I
or was this like the influencers who
make it look really cool yeah dude
George they're amazing tell me if I'm
wrong Lewis like
they take these old vans and they strip
them completely down and do they make
them so red and they take these awesome
photos like on a beach and it's all
those people have a lot of money
they can afford rent and they live in I
why is it
let me ask you this
what's so great about where you live
that you'd be willing to stay there in a
van
instead of move to another town or get a
roommate or a job where the rent is less
um I guess families here you know
okay so I love oh let me I love my
family I love them and
every bit of every all my family lives
in the same state they all live in Texas
and then I got an opportunity to go make
different types of money and have a
professional like so I moved because I I
had to and I still get to see my family
I love them I still couldn't see him
regularly but I had to move
so Louise you're not buying it what is
your rent
let's just talk get to the numbers 1200.
okay are you living alone
with a girlfriend okay are you splitting
the rent
no not yet
so she's not paying and you are
yes sir okay I'm we got 17 more
questions now what is your what's your
income
um I made 2800 I'm 30 30 000 a month
30 000 a month
I'm I mean I'm sorry 30 000 a year 2800
a month I was gonna say bro why are you
calling us I was like this doesn't
matter and what job are you doing
because I want that job okay so your
rent is almost half of you is that your
take-home pay the 2800
after taxes is that what ends up in your
bank
I I take it all because I work for a
private contractor okay
so here's one option
hey girlfriend we can't live together
and I'm gonna go get a roommate and then
your rent just went down to 600 bucks
and now we can breathe
there's one option right if you just
didn't even want to move
the other option is where else can I
live cheaper and that may not be super
viable in your area you may only get
down to a thousand which is still too
much based on your income so the second
question becomes how can I increase my
income to where I can afford the rent
okay so what kind of work are you doing
right now
um HVAC sheet metal installation
okay and you're making how are you
making thirty thousand dollars
are you what's your what's your actual
salary is it about 40 something thousand
no it is 30 something okay and you're
you're uh you're you're a 1099
yeah
are you are you putting money back for
taxes are you going to be in the hole
for taxes too
no I'll I'll hold it and then pay it
whenever do you have the money to pay
the taxes come April
um probably not in full yeah dude listen
you have too good of a skill and two and
it's such a high demand area what's
keeping you from going to work for an
HVAC company and making 85 000 a year
plus benefits
I don't have my high school diploma
do you have certification are you just
you can weld
no nothing nothing I just started I'm 20
years old and this is my first lease
like ever so I noticed this
the money is just too much yeah and what
other debt do you have
um I just have one credit card okay is
there a balance on there
yeah how much
nine hundred dollars okay and how much
money do you have in the bank
um right now of four hundred dollars
plus 900 in savings you got 400 plus
900.
yeah okay so a thousand dollars is your
starter emergency fund which then leaves
you
um
what's that 300 bucks on top of that to
start paying off this credit card so by
tomorrow we can get a thousand dollars
in the bank and your credit card debt is
down to six hundred that's our next plan
of attack is paying off that credit card
or cutting it up or closing the account
no more credit card we're gonna start
using a debit card do you have one of
those
yes sir okay that is plan number two
start using the debit card now we're
debt free and we have a thousand dollars
in the bank you tracking with me
okay then we're going to continue saving
a emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses not income just expenses so
start getting on a monthly budget I'm
gonna gift you one year of every dollar
premium that is our budgeting tool you
can set up a budget within minutes right
there on your phone on your computer and
it's going to help you pay attention to
every single one of those twenty eight
hundred dollars coming in every month
and you've got to start making a plan
for it and stretching it and part of
that is making hard decisions like
saying hey I can't live with you and I
can't afford rent so I'm gonna have to
move I need to get a roommate uh and I
need to get my cost down in order to
survive
and Louis did you grow up with with a
lot of money in your home or have did
you grow up with a family that struggled
financially
uh struggled financially okay I grew up
in this project okay Puerto Rico awesome
so man I'm so proud of you man for I
mean you're hustling you're getting it
done
one of the biggest shifts somebody who
grows up in poverty can make in in a
mindset
is this idea of how do I survive right
now which is I want to move to a van
that's a how do I survive right now two
where do I want to be in five years and
what do I have to start doing right now
to get there what certifications do I
have to get how do I get into a local
community college how do I start
grinding my way
towards where I want to be in five years
that's a totally different mindset and
that's the road we want you to be on
okay my brother and if you've got to get
an extra job right now if you could get
two roommates do whatever you have to do
to get that Financial stability under
use you can really start to build wealth
and break this generational property we
are so proud of you man